e
open the hearing on Senate Bill
566 relative to establishing a committee
to stutter foster care families and the
foster care system Prime sponsor Senator
chandley and look at that she knows the
first rule of testifying before this
committee turn the mic on
thank you thank you very much and good
morning Mr chair members of the
committee um my name is Shannon chandley
and I serve the people of marac Wilton
Milford and Amherst in District 11 in
the Senate um I come before you today to
introduce Senate Bill
566 as the chair said it is to establish
a committee to study foster care
families and the foster care system so
um I have served several terms in the
house and I'm in my second term in the
Senate and and throughout um my tenure I
have received calls from constituents
who have concerns about the foster care
system um you know these concerns um
sometimes people are quite desperate and
I'm sure you've heard some of the um the
concerns that the folks have raised to
me here in your committee um they are
include they include um uh uh certainly
a lack of of uh placements for foster
children um discrepancies between kin
and non-kin fostering uh requirements of
the Foster family and the living space
so this bill was a way of trying to um
look at the entire issue in one setting
for a while I tried to come up with um
certain ways to maybe uh how can we and
for lack of the better term I'll use the
word fix the system but I think that
it's not necessarily A system that is
broken it is a system that needs to be
um looked at so problems identified
challenges identified and solutions
created and I think that a study
committee might be the best place to do
that um I've reached out to various
shareholder uh stakeholders Advocates
and um members of the legislature who
are expert in this area and that
certainly includes um your chair and
honorable members of this committee and
I widespread support for doing this I
considered that there are there have
been um foster care subcommittees in the
uh oversite committee on
DHHS and there are other committees that
commissions and committees that look at
Children's Services but in Con in
consultation with a number of people
with expertise in the area seemed like
this might be the best way to move
forward um the bill is very simple it
sets up your standard uh study committee
and I know many of us are loathed to uh
put forward more study committees where
issues are extremely important we need
to do that and um the charge is uh to
assess the regulations and requirements
to qualify as a foster parent um the
special circumstances of foster care
provided by relatives and how to best
provide guidance to recruit Anda uh and
maintain um potential Foster families um
it's not limited to that and the the
committee as it does its work May find
other areas where there are issues and
identify those as um needing Solutions
so with that I ask you to look favorably
upon SB
566 and um happy to take any questions
if you have any thank you before I turn
them loose I'm just noticing the
all-star cast of House members you have
as
co-sponsors Greg Pearson patrino sidal
wow it is it is I said that I could I
reached out to folks with a real if not
expertise working knowledge of these
issues and certainly the members of this
committee are those folks as my father
often said don't throw your shoulder out
by excessively patting yourself on the
back any questions for the
senator representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question fabulous Bill
I just have one quick question
um on line8 it says the members of the
committee shall receive mileage at the
legislative rate is there a reason to
not include federal rate I'm just
thinking of the accounting nightmare for
the that's the
same it is not no it's not so if that is
something that needs to be addressed
absolutely not a problem to address it
for the uh for the members of the
committee who would be eligible for that
rate I think it's worth
um does anyone know the difference so
I I know there is the state rate and the
federal rate but I did not I I assume
both were um encompassed in legislative
rate but that I I am absolutely willing
to change that to accommodate
the federal rate is not um included in
your income tax on your
1040 we can elect as I recall the
federal rate or or the legislative rate
legislative rate becomes income I signed
off saying I wanted the federal rate and
that is how I've been paid for eight
years and that's that's the reason I ask
I can't imagine that this person gets
the federal rate for the rest of their
legislative rates while we have the
senator here um perhaps we could move
past our own wallets and ask her any
questions about the bill otherwise thank
welcome representative Raymond thank you
Mr uh chairman and thank you for taking
my question sure so this is only my
first term in the house and so I don't
have uh a huge famili it with study
committees so when a committee like this
is formed do you also investigate how
other states potentially are doing
foster care and if there's things that
we can learn from them or is it only
kind of a review of our internal systems
it would Encompass both because it
really is at the um the chair will the
committee will be established and the
chair is able to run the committee as um
the chair sees fit and I think that
given C certainly within the parameters
outlined in the bill the uh chair may
decide that the way to do this is to
call in some of um the people from the
state and from the other agencies with
whom the state contracts to understand
what the situation is the there may also
be um people who have some concerns or
complaints who want to come and address
uh raise those issues before the
committee and in terms of seeking
Solutions looking at other states is one
of the potential ways to find
Solutions do you have a candidate from
the senate in mind who might like to
chair this committee um there are
several able and willing folks and um I
would certainly um be happy to do so but
I'm I'm defer to um the Senate
president's appointment you have good
Senators on this too anyone
else representative McMahon thank than
Mr chairman Senator chandley uh just
wanted to ask uh in um for preface my
question is in optimizing the
performance level of the committee to be
appointed the starting point being has
there been an audit done of the foster
care system in in the state of New
Hampshire you know I would think that
would something be something that would
have to be looked into I don't know how
recently that has been done
would followup Mr chairman follow up and
then uh because the with with the goal
of getting this done while we're young
because this a very important issue uh
would would you be aware though of any
highlights of um subject matters that
would be prevalent as issue one and two
for the committee to address so I think
issue one is pro and of course again
this is subjective but issue one may
well be um how do we make sure that we
have enough foster care parents
available and issue number two is what
do we do to train and um and guide them
in their role as foster parents um and
and I guess I'll I'll make that issue
number one those two things are issue
number one and issue number two would be
what are the barriers why do people not
serve or why do they back away from
serving so a fiscal would be a reality
in in this
work a any any solutions that would be
proposed through legislation would
likely have a fiscal note but I'm not
sure of that right thank you senat
chairman what do you think
folks
thumbs thumbs or unofficial
votes oh you are are not in
Massachusetts anymore representative
only only one thumb
please thank you thank you who'd like to
move OTP on this make a motion to OTP
okay OTP by representative patrino and I
love to do bipartisan who what uh
representative
Nelson I I second but I do have a
question though because would we have to
you may have a question it's been moved
in second and so we may have questions
thank you Mr chairman um thank you um to
representative D Simone for um catching
that would we have to put through an
amendment to get rid of that uh
legislative
or this could be done by a floor
um excuse me could you uh call the role
and I'll speak and then I got to take a
phone call
okay we're gonna call the ro we're g to
role chair votes yes all
right the chairman votes
yay representative long yes
representative disimon yes
representative
bfit representative bfit is not present
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative Melvin is not
present representative uh
Gman yes representative LC yes
representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Gibbons is not present
representative Raymond yes motion
carries 13 to0 13 to0
not present who would like to write the
committee report yeah yeah we'll do
thank
much um repr Senator before you leave um
uh just we can be in touch often the
speaker asks me for recommendations to
committees for him to make the
appointment and if there is a particular
House member that in your work you have
identified as singularly qualified on
this I'd be interested in knowing that
okay and members of the committee I've
already got someone pass me a note
interested so if there's others just let
572 with uh
Senator bossy uh Senator Ward
sorry in for Senator Ward is Mr Grant FY
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh Senator Ward
is a bit under the weather this morning
she asked me to pinch hit we appreciate
the courtesy uh my name is Grant bossy
I'm the Deputy Chief of Staff in the New
Hampshire Senate here to introduce
Senate Bill 572 for Senator Ward the
prime sponsor uh Mr chairman the list of
house co-sponsors on this bill is not as
long long as the last bill you heard but
it is
quality uh the office of child advocate
brought
thisk the office of child advocate
brought this issue to Senator Ward uh in
the fall after conducting an in-depth
investigation into incidents of severe
child abuse where a number of infants
were not adequately protected in the
welfare system due in part to the
inability of dcyf medical providers and
law enforcement to timely and
effectively share
information uh that's that's why she
introduced Senate Bill 572 a bill that
establishes a commission to study the
sharing of confidential records between
law enforcement the medical community
child protection services and the legal
Community this problem implicates a
number of state and federal statutes as
well as policies and procedures across
these three sectors the commission will
study the relevant laws the barriers to
information sharing in this Arena of
multi-disciplinary teams who investigate
child abuse and how to prevent such
roadblocks since many agencies are
involved in the work uh we need to
safeguard the sharing of information so
our children are protected while their
privacy is also protected I want to
thank you Senator Ward thanks you for
your consideration and support of Senate
Bill 572 I would defer questions to some
of the Advocates we have here and if
there's anything they can't answer I can
get your questions to Senator warden
answer
Bickford thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um so what we've
got is a few um entities they can't
share information with each other all
right like hipper is a a problem for you
right yeah there there are privacy
concerns with both medical and law
enforcement they have their own
standards and getting through those
silos so people can know when children
are at risk is the challenge and hipper
is a federal War isn't it it is and so
now what about the law enforcement one
uh well there are various uh privacy
concerns when you're dealing with a a an
investigation so state and federal laws
this is what the commission would would
do is look at all the relevant laws that
you need to comply with to see how how
can how can we share information without
breaking either state or federal law the
multidisiplinary followup yeah thank you
uh Mr chairman the multi-disciplinary uh
thing is about uh professional people uh
getting together that are involved in
the child's issues right correct um and
they they've been doing that for some
years now and so how have they worked in
the past without this with the problem
of this federal law and uh and police
now police
are um can't share like
Juvenile Justice things criminal okay
and is there something else
about Polie can't share well without
getting in any specific cases that have
happened in the past Senator Ward saw a
specific instances where children were
at risk and the right people weren't
able to tell the other people uh what
they knew so that they might be able to
prevent a tragedy this is what the the
purpose of the commission would be is to
find out where they might be gaps in the
system is there follow up is are there
any other entities besides those two
entities
that have a a non-communication issue
well I think you'll see if you look at
the text of the bill there are a number
of stakeholders that are included and I
think uh you've got the courts you've
got the office of child advocate DCF
um the house and the Senate and um law
enforcement Hospital friction points I'm
looking for the yeah I I think that's
something the commission would be
involved in in fleshing out and and
finding I I couldn't tell you myself the
only two okay yeah thank
you anything
further saying nothing thank you so much
thank you and if the senator could uh be
in touch with me uh a little bit later
on when the names of the committee will
be put together I appreciate that thank
you thank you chair recognizes um I
think I get it right Amy Roy or
that's oh there we go okay good
morning uh my name is Dr Amy Roy I am a
pediatric emergency medicine doctor uh
with the Elliott hospital and then I
of sorry um I also conduct specialized
medical exams for the child protection
programs both with the Elliot and at
Dartmouth um I've been in that role I
think for about seven or eight years now
and uh certainly have encountered over
that time lots of issues with sharing of
information um as these
multi-disciplinary teams have sort of uh
taken root in New Hampshire you know I
think we in the medical community
certainly recognize them as really being
an invaluable tool for child protection
these provide uh a really critical and a
unique opportunity for um dialogue
between medical community child
protective services between law
enforcement sometimes other stakeholders
such as mental health and uh May serve
when we are able to come together and
have the kind of dialogue that we need
to have as an opportunity to really sort
of solidify and crystallize in uh in in
the sort of minds of those agencies that
there is significant reason for concern
for abuse and a real need to move
forward expeditiously um equally
importantly and I actually have a good
example of this uh sometimes what comes
out of these medical out of these
multi-disciplinary team meetings is an
equally important opportunity to resolve
a concern for abuse so that a family may
really be able to put that episode
behind them and to um and to move
forward uh a recurring stumbling block
as we've already heard referenced here
is um the capacity to share information
and certainly amongst the medical
community um a pervasive concern is
Hippa fear of a HIPPA violation and the
difficulty that most routine medical
providers have in really understanding
the nuances of HIPPA which is a big
complex piece of federal legislation and
in knowing where there are in fact
protections and opportunities to share
information um certainly it's hard to
believe that the intention of HIPPA is
to prevent the sharing of information
that is really germine to um to
Children's Health but we uh certainly
need help in understanding how to
communicate that what the sort of
guardrails are and how to function
effectively but also legally within that
multi-disciplinary team um setting I
think it's also important to remember
you know when we look at who is signing
consents to release information you know
in many of these instances a parent may
also be a perpetrator and that can be a
little bit complicated um so I think I
can say with real confidence that the
medical community would uh urge and
embrace the passing of this bill so that
we can have some clarity that would
allow us to um make these teams the
effective tool that we know that they
can
be and I'm happy to take any questions
if there are any any questions
representa Vice chair lawn thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for your
testimony uh the testimony that we get
here often is medical uh
because if you have medical information
at the school district for example
that's not their medical
information um it's your medical
information uh now my understanding
medically is I don't know about four
years ago or
sooner um if the entity was
under
um uh if they if they were held to the
same uh confidentiality requirements
then it could be passed is is that still
the understanding I'm not sure I
understand that completely well it was
mostly on when we were looking at uh
doing um video uh medical appointments
but via vi video okay uh the passing the
passing we we looked at the passing of
information um so that the other entity
wouldn't have to start from the
beginning
um and we found out that if there
beholden to
confidentiality then that information
can be passed to them are you familiar
with any changes of that sort no I feel
like I might not be the best person for
this question all right I think you know
between when there's sharing information
between medical providers who are really
operating under that same framework then
yes that is allowed um and beyond that I
don't believe so but I may not be the
person to ask okay all right thank you
any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
thank you J recognizes Lisa masio and
Jennifer Jones from the office of the
child
advocate
good morning everyone Lisa masio I am
the associate child advocate and with me
is Jennifer Jones one of our assistant
child Advocates I feel like I haven't
seen you all for a while you're we've
missed you too I've missed
you uh so we are here um as uh Senator
Ward's representative said uh this bill
was born of an issue that the office
discovered um last springish into the
fall
um as you know we are an independent
oversight agency overseeing All State
serving
agencies um and we support this bill
obviously as we helped write it we
worked closely with Senators Carson and
Senator Whitley in the oversight
commission for children's services
around this issue um to increase
protection for vulnerable children and
this piece of uh legislation is kind of
central to that work in increasing
communication um around members of the
multidisiplinary AR team so I'm going to
let um Miss Jones here talk about the
process that this bill was born of a
little bit in the specific players to
answer some of the questions that have
been
asked good morning lovely to be here
with you all I feel like I haven't seen
this Committee in some time myself so
it's nice to be back um so I want to
talk a bit
about kind of getting down to the tech
technical pieces of what a
multi-disciplinary team does and um why
it's so important that a
multi-disciplinary team is able to
collaborate so when there is an
investigation concerning child abuse and
or neglect um particularly with
reference to the investigation that
office of the child advocate conducted
um as Lisa mentioned um last year um we
took a look at approximately nine cases
where there were serious bodily injury
to 11 non-ambulatory infants so when
you're looking at a case like that
there's always going to be law
enforcement and dcyf so your States
Child Protection collaboration that's a
co- investigation because we're not only
looking at child safety but we're
looking a potential uh a criminal aspect
we know small infants can't injure
themselves um in the way that they were
injured in these cases that we we had um
been uh our office had been referred to
so so as we took a deep dive into the
communication so there were two aspects
to it we took a deep dive into reviewing
the records for each of these individual
cases meaning we were looking at the
communication between all members of the
multi-disciplinary team so that includes
law enforcement Child Protection uh
prosecution excuse me as Dr Roy
mentioned sometimes that includes other
entities um like your non- investigative
collaborative team members like uh
crisis centers mental health and so we
were looking at again the communication
between those uh entities and how they
were collaborating as an investigative
team and we also did a system mapping
review so that we could look at human
factors right things that were barriers
um or things that may have occurred or
happened um just in decision day-to-day
decision- making of those investigators
as well as system barriers so we largely
found that in almost all of those cases
there was a breakdown in communication
at some point in time um that could have
been in the onset where law enforcement
was responding and asking questions and
getting information without the presence
of DCF or um quite the opposite where
CPS was out responding in the immediate
and law enforcement hadn't been looped
in just yet and so those investigations
um there's a lot of moving parts so it's
not just about the child or infant being
seen in the immediate in the medical
information that may come out of that
one time appointment or that one time um
um uh you know referral to the Ed or um
you know there's there's lab work
there's um followup skeletal surveys
that may uncover or identify additional
injuries that didn't exist at the time
of the first initial examination and so
what happens is um in the respective
investigations as that information
continues to present itself so as you
know you can imagine it takes some time
for lab work to get back it takes
approximately two weeks for a skeletal
survey to car if the investigative
agencies are getting that
information at different times and not
able to share it creates a real
disadvantage about what one another
knows about their investigation and how
they're
collaborating um and so we found it
imperative um to have this um study
commission to really get to some of you
know representative bigford had some
great questions um along with
resentative long about like how does
that work how can you do that in a
legally defensible way and that's why we
want this study commission so what does
it look like when there's medical issues
right but they're specific to child
abuse and what and how do we pursue
those
investigations while honoring the
Privacy that all people are entitled to
medically but understanding that this
isn't you know this isn't just calling
up and inquiring about somebody's you
know average visit to their primary care
physician this is a child abuse
investigation and safety is Paramount so
what does that look like and how can we
navigate it in a way that um we're
really not running into um one
investigative agency having information
the other doesn't um as you can imagine
a collaborative investigation requires
good communication and timely
communication another um issue that we
were able to um elicit from our system
map is that this also um sort of in the
long game when these things go to trial
if dcyf Andor law enforcement don't have
the Child's full medical record and they
don't have all the records in their
Discovery medical professionals can't
speak to it at trial as expert Witnesses
and that really really can impede the
judge's ability to assess safety in a
way that they have all of the facts and
so there's a lot of it's a really multi
faceted issue and that's why we are
fully in support of the study commission
um thank you so much for your time I'm
happy to answer any questions oh sorry
did you have more I you can either ask
questions or I can tell you more and
then you can ask both of us questions up
to you
sir I'll I pick B okay I'll keep going
so um as Jen said it it is a very
complex area rather than us just try and
write a bill that would somehow cover
Hippa and law enforcement and dcyf the
study commission will help because some
of the specific barriers we were seeing
is it does appear under the current laws
and I I did attach you I know we all
like appendices appendix a which is a
compilation of all the relevant
rsas it is clear from those read
together that the legislature intends
for these multidisciplinary teams to be
able to communicate however fortunately
there are some gaps some of these
statutes require rul making which just
never occurred so that's a gap some of
them just sort of become circular in
logic so for example dcyf gets medical
records and they get law enforcement
records however they currently read
their confidentiality statute to mean
they can only disclose their records I.E
things they created their case notes not
even to include the cap exam that they
paid for and sent the child to so
there's this this like chicken in the
egg problem that dcyf now has a lot of
records and can't share it with anybody
else they can't give law enforcement the
cap exam they can't tell medical what's
happening um so that's um a gap that
needs to be solved however we didn't
want to just sort of infringe a solution
on them we wanted the players to come to
the table and say how can we overcome
that similarly law enforcement
especially during an active
investigation against a parent of one of
these
children don't necessarily want to share
notes about an active investigation
because if they give it to dcyf because
this is a court case they're required to
disclose it in Discovery so now you're
actually giving records to the
perpetrator so it's it's a complicated
issue in that mapping all of the parties
said we really want to fix this we
really want to be able to talk to each
other but these are all complicated
issues we need to sit down at a table
and figure out what to do uh that
mapping did also discover another Gap um
at the court that some of the current
laws around abuse and neglect area 169
see the definitions are being
interpreted in a way to require a much
higher standard than necessary so we do
have another bill I believe you're
hearing soon uh when it comes over s SP
459 addresses that issue so we we're
trying to kind of address the discret
issues and allow this multi-disciplinary
team which the legislature created but
execution now you get to ask questions
that's Vice chairman
long thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for your testimony uh
I mean this is probably going to put a
stick in the wheel uh but we hear
several testimony uh of parents being
left out of the loop I you know I I
understand there are some things you
want to keep from them if they're the
ones being investigated but we're off
often hearing that even if the court or
somebody deems uh that it wasn't at that
level they're still not hearing that and
and um the child is still either being
kept from them or so I'm wondering if
that's I mean I get this information um
confidenti Aly sharing um but also if
parents could be even a parent that's
not
um um that's not uh being investigated
for abuse uh they're not getting the
information um so they don't know what's
happening with their child they don't
know what one entity or another entity
whether it's law enforcement
DCF uh whomever um so I I I think that
would be I I think it would be helpful
knowing where the gaps are in with the
parents uh we know what we want to keep
from whomever is being investigated I
get that uh but my understanding through
um testimony uh from parents is that
they're not getting investigated however
they still can't get any information
about their child so this Bill thank you
for the question and I hear what you're
saying because we've we've heard similar
things frankly parents call our office
saying I can't figure out what's going
on um this particular Bill send them to
you than feel free um this particular
bill has to do with the professional
multi-disciplinary team which is created
under statute already it is only
professionals sharing information about
an ongoing open child abuse case under
some of the statutes though that I
included in this appendix though RSA 170
g8a is dcf's confidentiality statute
which is very clear that a parent who is
under
investigation is allowed to get in
information about their case unless the
department determines that disclosing to
that parent likely if they're a
potential perpetrator would um the harm
to the child would be outweighed so
that's within statute it's also within
um again sometimes there have been
administrative rules that should be made
that haven't been made or maybe are
outdated um but parents receiving
information I think would be a separate
issue that a parent would need to deal
with with these separate entities law
enforcement has rules around who's
allowed to see an ongoing investigation
which is usually nobody and then Hippa
as Dr Roy mentioned it is actually
usually the parent that holds all the
control in a Hipp of situation as far as
giving consent which again in this case
if the parent is the perpetrator
allowing them to refuse to disclose that
child's medical records can actually
really endanger that child um but
parents getting information is actually
part of some of these statutes and is
separate from this particular
multidisciplinary team just because of
the way it was established in stat right
thank
you
seeing no more cards on this Bill thank
what oh I'm
sorry representative McMahon sorry no no
that's fine you're multitasking as
always Mr chairman don't worry about it
I just have a question for see it's
moving up I used to miss representative
Raymond and I got that one solved and
yeah
sorry Cooperative collaboration to
achieve consensus is now in place
okay attorney I relative to the 170 G8
confidentiality uh that you kindly
provided at uh I want to ask your
guidance on relative to the authority
having jurisdiction it appears to be the
commissioner or designate on
whether information
that says here if it outweighs the need
for the disclosure then they can um deny
that would you have recommendations on
specific language that would need to be
changed in existing law so it doesn't
become a Quantum physic calculation as
to impact but it is application versus
interpretation of application of
distribution of confidential
information thank you for your question
I think this study commission could
potentially take up that that question
as part of of the multidisciplinary team
I can tell you from when I was a dcyf
attorney um so these aren't 91a requests
so they're not handled in quite the same
way these 170 g8a information requests
typically do go to the legal department
within any uh district office and then
the discussion is held um at that level
of weighing those pros and cons of
danger to that child for the disclosure
versus the parents right under the
statute to get the records it can go all
the way up to field administrator level
or you know dcyf State office level
typically the commissioner herself is
not involved in those conversations um
but it certainly could be um part of a
conversation around this statute I think
this multidisciplinary team because the
parent is not part of that professional
team That explicit question would not
come up but this statute's key as as far
as what information sharing means who's
assessing it and at what level so um P
perhaps language could be offered um I
think I don't know of any personal cases
where this has been an issue right now
it it is meant to the whole statute is
meant to protect children so it is
weighed with the child safety in mind
one followup Mr chair follow up um I'll
stipulate to agreeing with you on
protecting the children that's not up
for debate the issue is the application
of the protection for the children as
you both have correctly pointed out if
the commissioner is playing a major role
in this is there a representative I was
just looking at Who members of the
committee is there a representative of
the commissioner's office that then
would then that should be if not so
designated a part of this uh
collaborative effort so the folks that
are on this particular study commission
are relating more specifically to that
multi-disciplinary team so it is the
director of dcyf who would sort of
represent the field and then the a
representative of the DCF legal
department because it is the DCF legal
department that ultimately is making
these
interpretations of statutory release so
it is dcyf legal that has decided even
though this is our cap exam that we have
done we can't show it to anybody else
because that's how we're reading the
statute so I think probably especially
because DHHS is such a huge uh
Department the commissioner's office is
not really a person that's involved with
this multi disciplinary team
particularly but it is dcyf legal as
well as dcyf director who's ultimately
kind of assessing those specific cases
okay I'll leave it at that thank thank
chairman after Resolute search I see no
hands up so thank you so much thank you
and this uh concludes the hearing on
Senate Bill
572 Senator Ward and I had an extensive
conversation about a few aspects of this
bill so you are now being
handed an
amendment
and yes this is hot off the press the
amendment has been worked and reworked
um and once you
uh can I have one please sorry may I
have one excuse
me so once you get it I suggest you put
it side by side with
um the original bill the bill is
submitted and I'll walk you through the
made
and for the OCA purposes uh let me give
you a sneak peek uh for reasons I'll
elaborate everybody else on the
commission now becomes consultants and
the only members of the renamed
committee are five legislators this is
because of recently passed RSA
1449 but everybody who was not alleged
lator who was in the commission is also
being mentioned by title as consultants
because we want them there and then
there's a few other adjustments along
the way so this is not substantive to
the task of this group it is simply a
matter of bringing the membership into
compliance with uh an RSA so if
everybody has um both please look at the
original
26 line 26 says notwithstanding RSA 1449
the membership of the commission shall
be in other words I know it's in law but
we're not going to do it that way um
we're backing off that um and so if you
look over at the amendment page 1 line
11 the members of the committee and it's
named now a committee not a commission
shall be as before one member of the
Senate is appointed by the president of
the senate senate award suggests four
members of the House appointed by the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
one from this committee one from Health
and Human Services elderly Affairs
committee and two members from any
committee we want to make sure we get
the subject matter experts from the
house appointed as they will do in the
Senate at least one of whom shall be a
member of the minority party now look at
line 16 the committee shall te shall
seek testimony from various persons and
agencies in order to accomplish its
purpose these shall include but not
limited to that's the whole list of
people and the bill is submitted on the
top of page two it's the same folks we
want them there
but the reason the LSR was was was made
was large committees with Quorum uh find
sometimes they don't make their Quorum
they have difficulties in steering a
large ship so we want them to come if
they want to come to every meeting
they're welcome to if they only can come
to certain meetings that doesn't
penalize the work of the committee so
that's the main change But continuing on
in the amendment
therefore uh page two in the
amendment
um the original bill says this group
will meet 10
times and then it said the preliminary
report will be November 1st good luck
and then it said the final report will
be in 2025 which is after the
election so this we saw some
difficulties with that and so the 10
meetings is out they can meet as often
as the five of them are willing to meet
and the final report is due in
2024 so that is the amendment Senator a
Ward and I came up with um which we
think makes this a more wieldy
committee um so I'll give you a minute
to chew on that and ask me any questions
Mr chairman may I yes um some question
uh page two line 21 of which bill the
bill or the amendment the amendment the
amendment page two line 21 um same
question with with the since the other
Bill the malage members of the committee
should receive malage at the legislator
rate all I can say is I've been serving
on committees and commissions for eight
years now here and that's the language
I've always seen and I've never failed
to be paid well okay thank you so we'll
check that out representative um just to
get an official answer on that thank you
thank you anyone else Vice chairman long
uh thank you Mr chairman so on line 21
the uh 10 meetings of the original Bill
no this is on the amendment there is no
10 meetings in the
amendment line 21 line 21 is about
mileage you read that's a previous
Amendment Al this the amendment in play
is number
1397 oh I don't have that okay that went
passing by if anybody's got an
extra there were 20 some out of that I I
didn't take it because I thought I had
it okay yeah we have an extra right here
you so that's uh removed they can meet
10 times it'll be up to
them and any further questions on uh the
Amendments oh sorry yes representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman right past
representative McMahon yeah on um page
two line 25 it says the first meeting
shall be held within 45 days of the
effective date of this section is that
45 days from when the governor signs it
I feel like it it should be obvious and
then I started questioning it and was
like oh my well yeah you're in your
first term I figured that one out in my
second term so you're
ahead thank you that does not mean
informal but legal under 91a
conversations may not be held
individuals may not do research
individuals may talk with the people who
are coming to testify as experts just
official meeting has to be held within
45 days they can get to work now if they
want to quietly individually
individually okay yeah it just it feels
really tight thank
you well there's a lot of bills with the
exactly this
else I am are we ready to go on this
thumbs this one's pretty easy too thumbs
just one from yeah thank you then I open
the executive session on Senate Bill 572
and I move
Amendment
1397 is there a
second
second on the who's that Raymond on the
end yes oh I'm sorry I didn't see Miss
Perez
oh all right sorry one second
representative
Perez now any further discussion on the
amendment you see why it was done the
Senators signed off on this no Committee
of conference we're not worried about
bill
role chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman
long yes representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative Melvin yes
representative rosan yes representative
LC yes representative Patrina will vote
Yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes
absent and now the bill as amended I
move on to pass his Amendment
amended and uh representative
Greg any further discussion this speak
now the motion is ought to pass as
Amendment as amended by Amendment 1397
the bill is Senate Bill 572 moved by m
Pearson seconded by Greg would the clerk
please call the role jamond Pearson yes
Vice jamman long yes representative
disimon yes representative bfid yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative panck yes representative
Melvin yes representative grman yes
representative LC yes representative
patrin will vote Yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Rond yes motion carries
15 to zero with one absent any objection
to
consent hearing
none this closes the exec session on
Senate Bill 572 and I am reopening the
exec session on Senate Bill 566 any
objection to consent that was Senator
chandy's Bill it passed 130 I have a
question Mr chairman yes can it be on
consent if it needs an amendment for the
legislative or are we just going to
leave it as it was with legislative
mileage I think we can get a floor
Amendment if necessary in which case
it'll be pulled off consent yeah oh okay
okay thank you for the
clarification I'll take a Voice vote on
consent on Senate Bill 566 all in favor
oppos thank you okay and that closes the
566 now open the hearing on Senate Bill
359 raising the marriage age
to 18 and we have Senator iller to
also an Allstar cast of House coones
namely long Grossman LC
Petrino
and if you look down at the bill and
wonder why under committee it says
Judiciary and you didn't know this is
now the Judiciary Committee the fact so
if you see Judiciary not to worry about
place Mr chair are there copies I don't
have my actual copy of the bill just all
my supporting testimony shall I I don't
know um my assistant committee
researcher might know and if not there
you go thank
right and we'll just hold off one second
attention
okay I should have suggested after we
just looked at 572 if there's any uh
members of this committee that would be
interested in appointments uh I have a
ticket from one if there's any others
just send me a note or let me know um
when I make recommendations uh to the
speaker I think we're good Senator
please thank thank you Mr chair and
honorable committee members my name is
Deborah alcher I represent Senate
District 24 which includes the towns of
exor Greenland Hampton Hampton Falls
Northampton rye and stratum I am honored
to bring Senate Bill 359 to you with the
Wind of unanimous Judiciary Committee
ought to pass recommendation and a
consent vote consent vote in its sales
this proposal seeks to amend RSA
4574 and raise the age to enter into a
marriage contract to 18 years old as of
July 2023 10 states have banned underage
marriages with no exceptions requiring
marriage license applicants to be a
minimum of 18 years old Delaware and New
Jersey did it in 2018 Pennsylvania and
Minnesota in 2020 Rhode Island and New
York in
2021 Massachusetts in
2022 and Connecticut Michigan and
Vermont in
2023 in New Hampshire the average age a
woman enters into marriage is
26.8 and for men it is 29.3 years old
nationally according to the US Census
Bureau the median age for marriage is
approximately 28.6 years old for women
and 30 5 years old for men children
entering into marriage contracts is
wildly out of our current cultural norms
in the back of your pocket of your
packet are two graphs showing the change
in the entrance to the contract of
marriage for American men and women
between the ages of 2 between the years
of 2000 and
2023 New Hampshire allowed
215 child marriages
nine of them since the marriage age was
just recently raised to 16 child
marriage is a tactic used by child
traffickers to control victims the
center for for Disease Control and
prevention conducts the national survey
of family growth which gathers
information on pregnancy and births
marriage and cohabitation infertility
the use of contraception family life and
general reproductive health the survey
results are used by the US Department of
Health and Human Services and others to
plan health services and health
education programs and to do statistical
studies of families fertility and
health according to the nsfg after 5
years of marriage couples who married as
teens have a 38% risk of divorce and
those who got married between the ages
of 20 and 24 had a 27 % risk it drops
down to 10% if you wait until 30 to 34
to get married 80% of child marriages
end in divorce there is no data to
support child marriage children entering
into a marriage contract is just not a
path to success Senate Bill F 359
empowers Granite State adults to enter
into the contract of marriage as legal
adults previous objections to this
proposal included a wildly creative
hypothetical of a 17-year-old service
member shipping off to war and
potentially leaving behind a pregnant
girlfriend with no access to Medical
Services and while that makes for a
heart-wrenching Hallmark movie it has
absolutely no basis in today's reality
17-year-olds can only enlist with
parental permission the pregnancy
exception is instead used as a way to
avoid rape charges a marriage license
can indeed cover up sexual assault the
United States Department State
Department labels marriage before the
age of 18 as a human rights abuse just
before New Hampshire finally took a
modum of action in raising the marriage
age from 13 for girls and 14 for boys a
13-year-old girl in new New
Market was married off to her abusive
17-year-old boyfriend having been
coerced by her parents they are now
divorced another objection is a
comparison of our own personal and
familial marriage experiences to today's
Norms social norms have changed
Americans are delaying or putting off
all together getting married for longer
than before according to data from the
US Census Bureau the median average age
for men to first get married has risen
to 30.2 years old in 2023 while for
women the figure is
28.4 again I refer refer you to the two
graphs provided in your
back my
parents dated and married young very
young in fact they married both below
the median and average
ages and they celebrated almost 52 years
of
marriage they were married in
1968 five full years before the Equal
Credit Opportunity Act of
1974 that act finally granted women the
right to open their own bank Bing and
credit accounts outlawing discrimination
by sex in banking before that women
generally could not take out loans
without a male co-signer and lenders
often saddled female borrowers with
higher interest rates and larger down
payment requirements marriage at that
time was a financial best case scenario
the past 50 years have changed the
landscape of financial opportunity for
American women dramatically we need to
recognize the so socialization of women
and girls in the 1950s and 60s is so
very different than today I'm thrilled
to be joined here today by Advocates
from the national organization dedicated
to the eradication of child marriage in
America Unchained at last they will be
providing the committee with more
indepth statistics and personal
experience as a visual for a moment
think about the Hall of
Representatives now fill that room
halfway and those are the children
married
off imagine facing each one of those
kids trapped in a marriage contract they
cannot exit and say there just aren't
enough of you to justify my doing
anything to prevent this Hall from
filling up keep in mind none of those
children can gain sanctuary in a
domestic violence shelter if they need
it because they aren't old enough I want
to make it eminently clear that raising
the age of marriage does not in any way
shape or form pass judgment on anyone
else's marriagein marriage origin story
my parents
included we can celebrate those who
followed a Teenage Love Affair into a
decades long marriage while
simultaneously acknowledging that
marriage is more than a love story it's
a contract too a contract that should be
entered into by consenting adults we are
the policy makers we can make this right
and set the legal age to enter into a
marriage contract at 18 contracts are
for adults let's fix this in New
Hampshire and I urge the committee to
recommend Senate Bill 359 as amended
questions any questions for the senator
I don't have an amendment uh the bill
itself was amended by the Senate at the
top where it says as amended by the
Senate yes yeah that's what I meant
that's that was a good giveaway
yeah
no more amendments I it's all done yes
senator seeing none thank you so much
all right thank you very much Mr chair
and honorable committee members and now
with all the pink cards all in favor of
the bill most of the cards said time
needed to speak three minutes that will
now be imposed on everyone speaking and
by three minutes we mean 180 seconds
chair recognizes representative Timothy
Horgan from straford District 10 to come
minutes Senator iller could you fill out
a pink
yeah you
did okay okay the clock starts now thank
you so I'm Ron and Timothy Horan from
staford County District 10 which is just
a town of town of Durham so I was around
in um 2009 when we passed the marriage
equality law which actually
um to take advantage of uh same you know
same-sex marriage both parties had to be
18 and I think that was part of a
process of uh perhaps simplifying and
clarifying our understanding what
marriage is which is it's first and
foremost a contract between two people
um and we used to think that one had to
be male and one was was female and now
it's common place for people of the same
gender to marry but that's
uh that was something we recognized when
we uh created same gender marriage is
something that should apply to uh when a
a male and a female are U are marrying I
mean yes people who married their lives
are connected in all sorts of ways and
but there's lots of people
um who aren't married to each other who
are raising children lots of people
married to each other who are living
together lots of people who aren't
married to each other who are having sex
and that was true before 2009 it's even
more true now so I think
um I think having a Uniform age of 18 to
enter into the marriage contract is uh
is is just basically the way to go so
it's it's just not an
equal it's just not a valid relationship
if either party or perhaps in some case
both are not able to enter into a
contract without parental uh parental
horm Mission and of course the marriage
the divorce rate for people marry you
know child marriages is very high and
some cases uh the need to divorce
happens even
before um the party is is 18 and that
creates a very major problem since they
uh aren't able to initiate the divorce
proceedings um if they're under 18 so
that's um so I think I think just simple
common sense it just clarifies the
evolution we've already seen in maritt
law over the years and it as I said it's
a contract between those two people and
there's lots of other stuff involved but
it's basically a commitment between
those two people so they should both be
able uh they should both be adults and
able to freely enter in a contract and I
don't know if the military thing is
going apparently it's not going to come
up during this hearing today which is
good but it it has come up on the floor
in the past and um so the military um
the only
the the military U you can your child is
eligible for military benefits
regardless of whether you're married to
the other parent there's only issue is
maybe you can't live on the base if
you're not married 10 seconds represent
um the military thing which may or may
not come up during this debate C
apparently not during the hearing is non
is kind of nonsensical and if you feel
it's going to come up you probably
should have your researcher clarify it
cuz any questions for the represent
resentative than representative Panic
yeah I'm my understanding is once a 16
or 17y old enters into a marital
contract that they are considered by the
state an adult and that they could go to
see a lawyer and get the marriage
nullified or go through a divorce cuz
once they met ENT into a marital
contract they considered adults so I
think it that's what my understanding
was last year when this bill came that I
would just say I'm not necessarily the
right person answered i' I'm not a I'm
not a lawyer I've also actually never
been legally married but I have been in
Partnership so I would just say that's
probably something um we should have our
excellent research team clarify because
I'm not sure if that's actually true but
even if you are sort of Legally
considered an adult it's still more
difficult called if you're um under 18
and then there's problems you know after
the divorce is granted too so I would I
would just I would my first impression
is um I I disagree with what you're
saying but that's probably an issue that
uh we should have the research to
clarify if you think that's an issue
before we exec the bill and certainly um
it should be clarified before we have
the floor debate because I know I know a
lot of site issues have come in in past
floor debates and derail previous
attempts to pass this legislation so
that's about about all I have to say
although that was probably a fairly
lengthy answer but thank you any further
questions for the
representative seeing none thank you so
well thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Cassandra I
represent straford 4 which is straford
and
barington in the past few years there
have been increased attention both
globally and nationally about the need
to end child marriage in the United
States bills have been introduced in
many states in attempt to end child
marriage since 2016 at least 25 states
have straightened their marriage age
laws but it is not enough we should be
stepping up and fully protecting them
from this humans rights of abuse you may
ask how is this how is child marriage a
violation of child's rights children
have the right to education to live
their life free from violence children
have the right to the best health care
possible the right to a clean and safe
place to live and develop in the best
way possible and they have the right to
information on how to be safe and
healthy survivors and those that help
these victim these childrens will and
have testified in multiple venues that
these rights are are violated when the
children into marriages with adults the
US government has acknowledged that
child marriage is a human rights abuse
abolishing child marriage is a part of a
larger Global strategy to promote gender
equality and reduce poverty according to
the US Global strategy to empower
adolescent girls child early enforced
marriage arise from and often
perpetuates gender
inequality it is a human rights abuse
that contributes to the economic
hardship and leads to underinvestment in
girls education and Healthcare
needs child early enforced marriage
undermines economic productivity
threatens sustainable growth and
development and fosters conditions that
enable or exacerbate violence and
insecurity including domestic
violence it produces devastating
repercussions for a girl's life
effectively ending her childhood early
marriage forces a girl into adulthood
and motherhood before she is physically
mentally mature and before she completes
her education limiting her future
options depriving her of the chance to
reach her full potential and preventing
her from contributing fully to her
family and
Community let me further state that when
you open the door for child marriage it
is not only a child and child marriage
we are allowing we are allowing adults
to marry children we are allowing this
venue for human trafficking we are
allowing the corrosion of children there
is more at stake than teenage romance in
high school sweethearts marrying child
Brides face serious consequences girls
who marry at 18 or younger are at 30 are
at 23% higher risk of heart attacks you
have 15 seconds left to wrap it up okay
and heart attack strokes and diabetes
and
cancer I've been fighting this since I
was 15 years old that is one year older
younger than my great-grandmother's and
my grandmother when they were married at
16 thank you representative will you
take some questions from your colleagues
absolutely questions from your
colleagues representative Panic do you
know how many uh child marriages
happened in New Hampshire um in the past
year or two um I used to I haven't um
gotten the full update but I'm sure
somebody will be bringing that forward
it's zero and the year before I think
there was
to no somebody with the answers will be
bringing them forth so let us not
questions representative
Perez uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question you know that I'm
being very vocal about this issue and
then I always support anything that has
to do with child marriage but my
question to do is um on line two and
three uh no person below the age of 18
she'll be capable of Contracting or B
marriage or marriage contract as such a
person she be null or void
um this is my only
concern and I know that I'm a Survivor
that you know I was I was married when I
was younger but my concern is that we
have people coming from other countries
that we have different different points
of view and by not avoiding something
I'm I'm just concerned that not every
single marriage entering into abused
relationship or uh not work uh that's
the only concern that I do have so that
would fall under where we do we're state
to state type thing where we do
recognize that and if you get married
like out of state where they allow it or
out of the country where they do allow
that then we have to fall under Federal
Juris ction I believe that's the Full
Faith and Credit Clause of the
Constitution so they wouldn't suddenly
be unmarried when they moved to New
Hampshire thank you representative
patrino thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question would you
agree that the number of marriages that
take place in New Hampshire uh child
marriages in New Hampshire is irrelevant
if you believe that child marriage is is
wrong yes thank you you believe that
yeah good point representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and um I know I know
you have very good intentions in
protecting young women my question um
kind of um stem from some of the um
testimony from the representative before
you um
we have a problem with teenage girls
cohabiting with older men and with um
their teenage
boyfriend's
parents um you know living with with
them are you aware
of a young woman at the age of 16 or 17
or 15 who is in that situation would
they be able to go to a domestic abuse
shelter um I because they're underage I
believe anybody under the age of 18 will
be turned away from all domestic abuse
shelters because they do not have a
legal guardian with them and most of
those
that um like if someone is trying to get
away from their spouse or whoever then
in these instances of child marriages
there are many victims who have gone to
domestic violent shelters and who have
been turned away or the police have been
escorted back to escorting them back to
their parents or their legal guardian
who happens to be their husband who then
further abuses them even more because
they try to get away from them followup
yeah I think probably that my question
isn't really germy to your bill or
Amendment but maybe we can work on
something like that in the future
together if we're reelected yeah thank
you any further questions for the
representative seeing done come on back
okay and I do have flash drives for
anybody that wants data on um child
marriage yep do they come with
instructions for old people I can show
you how to use thank
you just want to give chance to the
office of child advocate if you have any
information to that question about
turnaways you want to come up and answer
that question you don't have
to okay they wave off they look
embarrassed I'm sorry I should have
texted you okay
all right the chair recognizes Emma
Futures you asked for two minutes I'm
going to hold you to
free thank you for the extra
minute good afternoon oh it's still
morning five minutes good morning uh my
name is Emma I'm the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures new Futures is a nonpar
nonprofit organization that solves
problems through policy change um we are
here in strong support of Senate Bill
359 because it reduces adverse childhood
experiences or Aces um which have been
long uh linked to Serious long-term
health effects um not just in childhood
but throughout uh adulthood as well um
when children are engaged in uh a
marriage contract before they reach the
age of majority um typically these
stories are accompanied by
um severe trauma sexual emotional
physical abuse all of these highly
traumatic events contribute to lifelong
consequences such as um as you've heard
heart disease um mental health concerns
substance use disorder um children who
have experienced four or more Aces have
higher rates of being uh trafficked um
something as simple as back pain all of
these things can be mitigated by having
protective factors in place having
supportive uh adults outside of their
homes having
um uh access to services this bill is a
really important and critical step in
establishing one of those protective
factors protecting our young kids from
entering into a contract and having
these traumatic
experiences I'll also note that this is
part of a national movement there have
been um 11 states soon to be 12 states
that have um enacted legislation similar
to this um to end child marriage in
their states additionally um to answer
rep panic's question there have been 215
minors married since 2000 between 20
2000 and
2023 um since 2019 there have been nine
children who have been married 83 % of
these were girls wed to adult men with
an average age difference of 4 years
older from the child who was married and
the 2018 legislation was certainly well-
intended but only protected about 4% of
the individuals that it needed to
protect the rest of those those um cases
are aged 17 and above every single life
is important even one child marriage is
too many um we have done as a state so
much to invest in our system of care and
invest in the mental well-being of our
children I think this is a a critical
next step in ensuring that we mitigate
Aces as much as possible happy to answer
any questions to the best of my
ability you have 10 seconds in the bank
for next time you come thank you any
questions representative Panic you're on
a role today yes I am thank you chairman
um out of those marriages that occurred
do you have the the statistics on how
many ended up in divorce I don't have
those statistics off the top of my head
you seeing nothing further thank you so
much thank you so much chair recognizes
Linn Curry Stanley from the National
Association of Social Workers New
Hampshire chapter and thank you for the
good handwriting well thank you for
recognizing my good handwriting um good
afternoon uh members of the committee uh
for the record my name is LIN cier
Stanley I'm a social worker I am the
executive director of the National
Association of Social Workers New
Hampshire chapter and I live in
Penacook uh social workers have a number
of concerns uh about child marriage this
is this is not a maturity issue this is
a legal rights and responsibilities
issue um 30 40 50 year olds may not be
mature enough to get married um it is
about the legal rights and
responsibilities that you uh obtain Once
you turn
18 uh we are concerned about
parents prematurely relinquishing their
parental rights and handing it over to
another an 18-year-old a
45-year-old making them their
technically their legal guardian we are
concerned about um how child marriage is
used as a tool of child traffickers
somebody taking a 16-year-old across
state lines for an nefarious purposes is
committing a felony somebody taking
their wife across state lines is just
going to
Vermont we are also concerned about of
course about the mental health impacts
that child marriage can have we are
concerned for those children we are
concerned for the adults that they
become we're concerned for the social
workers who have have to help those
often young women put the pieces back
together yes it is small
is it may not be meaningful to many but
it is absolutely meaningful to those who
it affects thank you very much and I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
might
have thank you none thank you for your
testimony handwriting in a minute and 10
seconds to your credit
account Becca Powell from Unchained at
last and that intrigued me earlier when
term good afternoon my name is Becca
Powell and I'm here representing
Unchained at last uh the Survivor Le
nonprofit that's dedicated to ending
forc and child marriage in the United
States uh the 2018 legislation that
raised the marriage age to 16 was very
well-intentioned but it didn't go far
enough
96% of the minors who married in New
Hampshire before 2018 were aged 16 or 17
so the 2018 legislation only protected
4% of the individuals it was intended to
protect but s SP 359 isn't about
creating a better system to enter minors
into marriage this bill will do what 11
other US states have done and set the
marriage age at 18 no exceptions uh
because child marriage itself is
inherently dangerous as you heard this
has nothing to do with maturity minors
don't automatically wake up on their
18th birthday with some Newfound wisdom
or ability to make good decisions what
they do wake up with his all the rights
of adulthood they didn't have even the
day before and that's so crucial
especially for a minor who is being
forced to marry before a minor turns 18
they can't even open the door and leave
home to get away if their parents are
planning an unwanted wedding for them uh
minors who run away from home are
repeatedly repeatedly can be deemed a
child in need of services and summon to
a court hearing to determine further
disciplinary action in our experience
domestic violence shelters across the US
will routinely turn away unaccompanied
minors and youth shelters in general are
not a solution uh they typically only
limit the state to 21 days and their
main goal is to reunite that with their
parents uh additionally a minor can't
easily retain an attorney because
contracts with minors are voidable and
they generally can't file a legal action
which just creates additional obstacles
for them and representative panic I want
to address a question you asked earlier
yes miners are automatically emancipated
upon marriage which does bring some
limited legal rights of adulthood
however these rights do arrive too late
to prevent a forced marriage that minor
would first have to undergo the trauma
of a forced marriage which in our
experience can typically mean being
pulled out of school raped on her
wedding night and forced into a life of
domestic and sexual servitude and you
can't undo this trauma and you can't un
rape a minor just by giving them some
limited rights of adulthood by
emancipating them afterwards also the
rights of emancipated minors are as I
said limited in our experience domestic
violence shelters will turn away even
emancipated minors and emancipated
minors often have trouble accessing the
rights that they do have imagine for
example how a landlord would feel uh
about renting an apartment to a 16 or
17-year-old uh and because of these
limitations globally child marriage is
recognized all child marriage is
recognized as being forced marriage
because minors just simply do not have
all of the rights of adulthood they need
to enter any contract let alone a
contract as serious as marriage and
because of this when girls have reached
out to Unchained who provides Direct
Services to those who are facing forced
marriages when girls under 18 have
reached out and asked for our help and
have learned of their limited legal
options we've unfortunately seen some
turn to self harm and even suicide
attempts uh so for all those reasons I
ask you to please do what the Senate did
and vote Yes on SP 359 and I'm happy to
answer any questions
representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um are you
familiar with our present
law here in New Hampshire yes uh 16 and
17 year olds can uh enter into marriage
with the consent of one parent and
judicial
review follow up um because I um do
think that um they do have certain
legal uh rights under that law so as I
said yes when they're married they're
automatically emancipated and they do
get some limited rights of adulthood um
but as I mentioned those rights arrive
too late to prevent a forced marriage
and you know that trauma unfortunately
can't be undone just by giving them some
of those limited rights of adulthood um
and additionally as I mentioned those
rights are only limited and in our
experience domestic violence shelters
minors thank you for your testimony
thank you so
much chair recognizes Michelle is it
Foundation that's what it
says well I'm glad you could read my
handwriting I'm sure it was not only
that I'm intrigued tell me what aha
Foundation is sure aha Foundation is a
nonprofit no tell me what it means oh
it's our Founder's name excuse me aan
hereli she was a survivor of forced
marriage and female genital mutilation
aha
okay
thank you I am Michelle hanash I am the
director of policy and women's programs
at the AHA Foundation we are a nonprofit
working to unharmful practices like
child marriage we also receive those
help requests from individuals fleeing
forced marriages across the us including
for minors and it is because of these
heartbreaking stories that we are so
adamantly in support of
s359 and keeping the marriage age at 18
and eliminating the dangerous loopholes
that allow for children to be entered
into marriage and I believe in the past
it had been asked whether it would be a
good idea to add a military exception to
the marriage age that's not currently
the law and that's not proposed in Sp
359 but I'd like to take just a few
minutes to explain why that would not be
a good idea so first to explain the
common misconception you do not need to
be married to list the mother of your
baby or anyone for that matter is the
beneficiary of your death benefits and
as you heard children receive service
members benefits regardless of their
marital status and using other spousal
benefits that would not apply like
health insurance or housing to a
non-married partner are not a reason to
keep children entered into child
marriage using someone's Current
financial dependency as a as a
justification for child marriage will
only keep them further dependent and
ryant on public assistance government
aid for a lifetime we all believe that
there are other Solutions than entering
children into contractual sexual
relationships in order to receive
housing or Healthcare we would say
Medicaid not marriage and sadly people
sitting here today testifying in support
of this bill have had to help children
who were being forced to marry service
members and those children receive
protection as much as any child being
forced to marry a civilian and you
should know military exceptions are not
the norm only one state Alaska has a
military exception we couldn't find any
any country even in a war torn area like
Afghanistan that actually has a service
member exception we have support from
service member advocacy groups who are
saying don't support child marriage in
our name a a letter of support was
submitted by protect our Defenders
saying just this we urge you to listen
to them and not cling to child marriage
a harmful practice that prevents girls
from having Liberty economic freedom
educational opportunities we urge you to
pass this legislation as soon as
possible thank you so
much any
questions
aha representative I might as well just
get everybody upset with me we're not
upset with you after I say this we'll
our lunch quickly thank you Mr chairman
um my confusion here
is we're advocating for genital
reassignment surgeries for children
under 18 years old but you're not going
to allow them to be married under 18
years old I can't seem to line those two
different thought processes up I think
something like this needs to be left
alone it has to be a question
representative I mean how do you how do
you how do you justify that part and
then this part here where you're saying
you can't get married we'll reassign
genital surgeries but we won't allow you
to get married it just how do you as
square that away sure thank you for the
question as as people have mentioned
marriage is a contractual relationship
18 is the age to enter into
contracts setting the marriage age at 18
I should say keeping the marriage age at
18 and eliminating the loopholes is
entirely consistent with the laws when
it comes to entering into a contract and
we shouldn't um allow children to be
abused used because of other issues that
are being debated when it comes to
legislation ending child marriage is
entirely consistent with the laws on
childhood and on contracts and
otherwise having loopholes in the law
completely makes a mockery of of so many
other laws when it comes to
children thank you any further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you so much Tre recognizes Mr Dana
Al
minutes yeah good morning Mr
chair uh thank you uh just to address a
few things I heard earlier to begin with
a brief anecdote I once found myself
outside an abortion clinic speaking to a
young
African-American gentleman very upset uh
that his uh European girlfriend uh was
not going to allow him to be a
father and so it seems uh uh this is off
topic please speak to the bill a brief
anecdote to uh frame the bill please all
right so the First Choice it seems is
death and I'm speaking to R Perez's
content uh a comment and after facing
death we Face birth and then directly to
rep Perez's comment the next choice we
face is a gender assignment and whether
we are think we ought to be a boy or a
girl at a very young
age uh after that we Face the choice of
who we find
attractive after that we chase the
choice of whether to consummate that
after that it
seems uh today's reality is we decide
whether that ought to be a marriage
death and um I find this a curious order
of
events and if you go to the most recent
Supreme Court
case uh o oberfell
at
uh
2 2590 it says a third the US Supreme
Court says a third basis for protecting
the right to marry is that it safeguards
children and families and thus draws
meaning from related rights of
childbearing procreation and education
going back to pierce V Society of sis uh
sisters uh protecting religious
minorities so while many of view
marriage is a legal contract
if you look at line 15 here it says no
magistrate or minister of religion so
solemnize any
marriage I submit there are many who
view it not as a legal contract but a
religious
um I'm not sure how this bill is written
doesn't run a foul of
oberfell both in terms of
due
process uh recognizing full faith and
credit and recognizing First Amendment
rights and granted it may be a very tiny
minority but I would just urge you to
consider this in the broader context of
all of these issues and at what ages all
of these sort of events ought to occur
thank
you any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony um
I do know that in Most states the
minister of religion is both a minister
of the sacrament and um a legal
representative of the state and I do
know that in those states where
sometimes those are in Conflict uh that
is a
discussion can the minister solize
matrimony for the church and not be a
representative of the state when those
two things Clash I'll just leave that as
an open issue okay thank you these are
just things I'm hoping you'll consider
as
you finally the chair recognizes uh
Fredy rice from Unchained at last and
you two have three
minutes Brooklyn I can talk very
quickly I'm Fredy Reese I am here as
thank you un Shan at last and I am a a
forc merit Survivor so this is very
personal for me I'm also an advocate
through unchain Atlas we work with
survivors who are aping Force marriage
and I'm an expert on this issue my
research and writing have been published
extensively I want to talk about how the
current law in Massachusetts I'm sorry
here in New Hampshire allowing 16 and 17
year olds to be entered into marriage
actually encourages legalizes and
incentivizes the trafficking of minors
under the guise of marriage the way it
works is the federal government does not
specify any minimum age for marriage and
this is a really dangerous and gaping
and shameful loophole in federal law
that allows and encourages the
trafficking of minors in the US and
mostly it's girls who are traffi for the
US citizenship forced to marry adult men
overseas who get a visa and a path to
citizenship it also encourages and
legalizes the opposite men in the US can
bring in traffic sex traffic girls from
overseas minor girls under the guise of
marriage and it's perfectly legal so the
way it works though is that USCIS and
the state department are allowed to
approve the petition of a spouse for a
spousal fiance visa involving a minor
only if the marriage would be legal in
the state where the couple will reside
and that means that right now in New
Hampshire USCIS and the state department
can approve these petitions for minors
as young as 16 and 17 almost all of our
neighboring states in fact every single
one except for Maine has addressed this
problem by making the marriage age 18 no
exceptions because that way USCIS and
the state department cannot approve
these marriages but here in New
Hampshire our girls are not being
protected and this is not a small
problem by the way the US Senate
Homeland Security committee issued a
report in
2017 that showed that in the decade
leading up to that report there were
almost 9,000 petitions for a spousal
fiance visa involving a minor as young
as 13 that were approved by USCIS and
the younger party was a girl in 95% of
those cases let's catch up to the rest
of our uh to the rest of of our
neighbors and uh 11 states across the US
that have solved this problem by making
the marriage age 18 no exceptions and
stopping the legal trafficking of
minors any
questions representative Nelson hi thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question I just I wanted to um just
get some clarification from you
um so you're saying that even if we have
uh per
RSA age limitations and residency
limitations here in New
Hampshire already in law that the
Federal Government Can supersede
that so what I'm saying is the federal
government cannot suped the minimum age
but it can follow the minimum age and
since the minimum age now is 16 that
means minors at age 16 or 17 can be
legally trafficked because USCIS can
approve that if we made the marriage age
18 the USC yes would not be able to
approve the uh spousal or fiance visas
for minors as young as 16 and 17 who are
being forced right now to uh marry adult
men overseas so they bring traffic for
their citizenship can I please have a
follow follow um I believe in current
statute um both um parties have to be
New Hampshire residents my understanding
is that one party needs to be a New
Hampshire
resident oh thank you
any other
questions and Cher I wonder if I could
also address a question that was raised
before regarding emancipation so there
was discussion um representative panic I
hope that my colleague Becca explained
why the Emancipation that you're right
once you're married you're emancipated
unfortunately those rights arrive too
late to help somebody who is being
forced to marry something that we see
almost every day at unchain at last
because these girls reach out to us and
we have to say well nothing we can do
until you're married but beyond that
actually the automatic emancipation upon
marriage is extremely dangerous public
policy because once a minor is married
and emancipated they lose their parents
financial obligation to them and
typically before we emancipate a minor
here in New Hampshire under the new
emancipation statute we first make them
prove to a court that they are
self-sufficient in their personal and
financial affairs but nobody is looking
at that when we're emancipating minors
just because one of their parents
decided it was time for them to get
married because this can happen with
just one parents consent in most cases
then we're forcing these minors to
become financially dependent on their on
their spouse which is a known risk
factor for domestic violence but it also
creates another perverse incentive for a
parent to force their own child to marry
what we're seeing is that parents are
using this as a way to unilaterally
terminate the parental rights of the
other parent they can one parent can
marry off their 16 or 17-year-old
without even notifying the other parent
and then the minor is emancipated and
there goes that child support obligation
you never wanted to pay or the child
custody battle you want to get out of
and in fact what a case like this went
up to the Idaho Supreme Court where a
woman found out her AR strange husband
had paid someone money to marry their
16-year-old daughter so he could get out
of their child custody battle and she
lost when she fought it up to the Idaho
Supreme Court Supreme Court said child
do you seeing nothing further thank you
for your testimony thank you please vote
Yes on S SP 359
now just a little straw poll we don't
have to exact this bill uh unless we all
want to so is there anybody who thinks
we should wait before we exact put your
thumb
up seeing no
thumbs that means we can go forward to
exec this bill so I closed the hearing
on Senate Bill 359 and I now open the
motion I'm ready to write I don't I I
will put all the letters down even
though I don't say them right yes yes
LEC got it I move op to pass ought to
pass second that and Patrina patr
you V
discussion I sensed on the part of a few
folks a little bit of hesitancy and
that's okay that's why we have the
discussion representative Damon thank
you Mr
chairman um I took the time to look it
up uh
on line 12 it says no magistrate or
minister religion shall som solemnize
the marriage doesn't say anything about
justices of the peace who in this state
magistrates and a Justice of the Peace
can solemnize a
marriage so there's one issue that I
have with the bill could we look at just
that one one would think that no justice
of the peace May commit an act against
an RSA and if that person does so that
person would be subject to some
strictures and the ACT would be null and
void well doesn't say we can't do it
know what's your pleasure we can hold up
and the
argument
RSA and if you think you're doing it I
think I'm a star for the Red Sox so it
yeah anyone else for discussion
representative
Bickford um the the issue of military
was brought thank you Mr sorry that was
that was wrong this is discussion I just
call on you oh okay um anyway military
was brought up for an issue and one of
the things in the military as I recall
they pay more if you have a wife or
spouse I should say and so they've
created a benefit that makes
this uh advantageous to get married at a
younger age a lot of people go on the
service at 18 19 years old and they I'm
going to say their girlfriend um wants
to be with them or at least on base and
like I say they get money doing this I
know uh my my daughter was not underage
but that's they get extra money for
being married you know that's not
something I really believe in because I
believe in equal pay for equal work but
that's the way the system is right now
and
so I I'm hesitant to change because of
that representative ofac yeah so um I
have researched this um I've talked to
many of my friends who are military
members I have talked to my father who's
military member there is no room for a
wife when it comes to basic training
when they enter into the military there
is no wife or spousal housing they come
with the trunk that they are given and
the clothes on their back and then they
are introduced into basic training yes
they do have housing but they follow a
chain of Comm and like the military does
whoever is higher up in the chain of
command they get that housing first and
the military has realized that marrying
their they realized that is an issue in
their that they're having with a lot of
their members um and I know I'm not sure
if there's been discussions of it I know
that I've talked to many military
members who have said that that is an
issue that they're trying to face right
now of military members especially their
younger boys marrying off just to get
benefits When in fact there those
especially with the pregnant girls um
the girls that are pregnant um they have
found other there's better ways to go
about it than just mirring off just for
benefits I think that's and also if they
find that they are marrying just for the
benefits then they will be court
marshaled and handle the way that the
military will handle it they don't just
let anybody get married just to get more
money they tend to have checks and
balances in that military to
prevent members just to receive more pay
just from having a ring on their finger
rep Vice chairman
long thank you Mr chairman
um yeah this is this is the these
discussions qualify why I believe that
nobody should be married under the age
of 18 I mean we're having a discussion
about a person going at the service that
may get another 20 bucks a week if he's
married so we're gonna you know so let's
incentivize that underage marriage so
somebody entering the service could get
extra 20 bucks or whatever they get I'm
sure it's not very much um you know and
then we have the discussion on um you
know other other discussions on nothing
to do with marriage and the sanctity of
it but just an an advantage uh that's
why I you know I'm sticking with if
you're not 18 years old you're not
getting
married representative
Raymond thank you Mr chairman so just to
kind of follow up on that it's called so
what happens in the military is you get
um a one-time bump when you add a
dependent it is not when you get married
it's when you add a dependent so that
dependent could be a spouse but it could
also be a a
child um and it it's interesting that
we're having this discussion and I'm I'm
reminded of um one of the
representatives who spoke who pointed
out that we allow only samesex marriage
starting at 18 so if you have a gay
military member at 17 who has gotten
permission from his parents to join the
military and they want to get married
now so that they can have that spousal
benefit they're not allowed to they're
only allowed to do it if it's opposite
sex apparently so to me for the fraction
of a percent of individuals who this
might apply to it's not a reason to put
in danger all of the other individuals
who are at risk of child trafficking um
and again the the bump is a onetime
thing when you add a dependent um under
their I for what it's called the it's
their enrollment system it's the acronym
is deers but I don't remember what all
the the letters stand for but basically
it's adding your dependence to their
system and it's for base housing
increase
representative
Gord representative Gabby grossan
see at least it's the same first
letter the first letter know thank you
worse thank you
um so this is my third term here and um
this has been discussed since my first
term with um representative Cassie L
bringing this forward for us um and I
absolutely support this
legislation um going round and round it
it my head you know we're putting kids
at risk we're putting young adults at
risk so whatever benefit May
outweigh whether it's a bump and pay or
what housing whatever it may
be the effect on our
society when we have
traumatized individuals that have
experienced trauma
and
coercion that's going to affect us down
the road
um the other piece that's always come up
is this notion
that a young person under 18 can can't
access help if they're in a domestic
violence
situation that has continuously come up
over and over being turned away from
from support and help because they're a
minor not being able to get a lawyer I
remember our first term it was I don't
think you could get a hotel
room as you know you couldn't get a
hotel room so but you could get married
um so once again here we are and I'll be
voting um in support of raising the
you the chair wishes to thank Gabby M
Grossman for her
contribution and now the uh chair
recognizes representative Greg thank you
Mr chairman um I think you know there's
a lot of a lot of things when we look
this bill and and between the house bill
that we had um this last year and then
this bill you know we're always looking
at you know a what type of kiddo in this
day and age is getting married that
early and we always go back to these
abuse things and and I think there's a
another thing that we're kind of missing
here and I know that the New Hampshire
way is we have our own little unique way
of doing things and that's that's
usually pretty great when we start to
see all the states around us um passing
these these marriage laws where we're
going to 18 what does that make us it
doesn't make us the outlier who needs to
play catchup what it makes us is it
makes us more attractive who is it
making us more attractive too it's
making us more attractive to these
traffickers yes we've only had so many
marriages in this last year but let's
look at it we have a ntion international
problem of trafficking especially with
internet especially with kids having
their phones and being able to get
online and meet up with people and stuff
we will make ourselves a very attractive
state for child traffickers to come so
even though we haven't seen that yet
that's something to keep in mind when we
are one of the only islands on this
particular matter so I will be voting
for this for a million different reasons
but that's an added one thank
you representative
Nelson um I'm feeling ambivalent right
now one way or the other but my concern
is that um is
this we have such a large larger problem
with um human trafficking sex
trafficking of minors and raising the
age of marriage to 18 is not going to
solve that and also in domestic violence
situations of minors who are
cohabitating so I am hoping that my
colleagues will join
me should we be reelected next time to
actually address the real problem that
you well my comment is uh when I was
young I visited my family in rural
Canada a little town called pearsonville
New
Brunswick and at 14 people were
responsible they did not have
adolescence you grew up quickly because
the cow had to be milked the absence of
Which is far more serious than you
didn't take out the trash every other
day and I noticed my cousins in Canada
were because of this much more mature
and so to get married at 15 and 16 was
not a maturity
problem well that's not the people I see
everywhere else I go even in rural
Canada as a result what might have been
okay there 60 years ago I do not believe
is okay here now and so I will be voting
for this
bill anyone else yes representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson um I
will admit that I voted against this
bill last year however um times have
changed in a very short period of time
and I'm very concerned that a same-sex
marriage is required to be 18 but we're
not providing those same protections to
the young women in our state um I will
this representative
Perez uh thank you Mr uh chair for
allowing me to speak um as you know uh
last year I was very vocal about this
bill um supporting RAC and data
h218 as someone who um again
um have life experience with
um basically um I was only 15 years old
and my ex-husband he was 47 years
old um and someone who didn't know the
language uh someone who didn't know the
rights um I had 11 years
of trauma pain and um
struggles um and I don't wish anyone
because those scars um even though that
I feel like I heal um they're going to
be there for the rest of my life um and
I don't wish anyone not even my worst
enemy to go through what I have
experienced in 11 years on my life so uh
call the motion before us on Senate bill
359 is ought to pass move by
representative LC seconded by
representative patrino would the clerk
please call the role chairman Pearson
yes Vice chairman long yes
Representative disimon no representative
bfid yes representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panic yes representative Melvin yes
representative grman yes representative
LC yes representative Patrina will vote
Yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes motion carries 14
to1 any objection representative D Simon
to consent no no objection it's on
consent and representative back before
you leave today a nice little blurb for
the clerk please congratulations this
concludes the exec session on Senate
Bill 359 I wanted to go way into the
lunch hour because I wanted a lot of
people who came here to see the
disposition of this
today now we're going to come back at
11:5
e
you
okay let's go Senate bill 506 if you
watch Downtown Abbey and remember Carson
this is a different Carson introducing
the
bill very much sir good afternoon Mr
chairman and The Honorable members of
the House children and family law
committee for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14 which
comprises the town of Auburn Hudson and
londonairy and I have for your
consideration this afternoon Senate Bill
which seeks to align other statutes with
the juvenile delinquency statute RSA
169b which provides that a delinquent
includes anyone under 18 years of age
um there's only three points to this
bill this is a technical cleanup bill
when the state raised the age of a
juvenile for 17 to 18 a few spots in
statute were missed and this bill would
clean up those remaining references to
177 and I'm concluding my testimony Mr
chair and um wow the attorneys that are
here that requested the bill be filed
will be more than happy to answer your
questions any questions for the
senator seeing none thank you so much
thank you Mr chairman and the chair
recognizes I'm going to say attorney
Steven Andre
you know they're trying to get me to go
to law school I'm getting law books for
Christmas now so well I I was going to
say you had mentioned the Rules of
Evidence book yeah I read it four times
with the footnotes I think that book
costs over
$200 the little tiny skinny one yeah
anyway the chief gave me a copy and I
know it's going to be on the test so
four times it really is um my name is
Steven ERS I'm an assistant County
Attorney at the marac county attorney's
office I've been a prosecutor for over
20 years now um just to not reiterate
what Senator Carson said but essentially
this bill um in 2017 the age for entry
into the criminal justice system was
raised from 17 to 18 years old and there
were a number of statutes that were sort
of lagging behind that didn't get
changed this goes back looks at those
statutes and changes the age to 18 so
that everything is aligned now and
unified I'm happy to answer any
questions
as was you say there was also a handout
that the
handout that has everyone who supports
it written in it wow thank you any
much no other pink
cards so therefore I conclude the
hearing on Senate Bill 506
FN and what do you think yeah y yeah the
last time I testified and said this is a
housekeeping thing two hours later it
was turned into something totally
different it was a significant
Improvement thank you Lucy
Weber but I don't use those words
qualifies all right then I will open the
executive session on Senate Bill 506 and
who would like to make a motion this
gives you the honor of writing the blur
of Representative
ball you cannot withdraw that
so who can second oh it's Greg yeah
discussion
middle in the
short Molita Malia Malia
wow yeah
discussion I've learned uh
representative Grossman's middle name
during this break anything
else all right we have a motion before
us on Senate Bill 506 FN the motion is
to pass by representative Ball seconded
by representative Greg would the clerk
role chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman
long yes representative diamon is not
present at the moment representative
bfid yes representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panck yes representative Melvin yes
representative grman yes representative
LC is not present representative Patrina
will vote Yes representative perz yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes motion carries 13 to zero
any objection to
consent saying none on to consent it
goes this concludes the exec session on
Senate Bill 506 and now open the hearing
on Senate Bill
498 uh relative to
dcyf and in today's uh
exciting episode the part of um
what you're not coming back till
1:30 three more minutes we have three
clock but it's Tuesday not Wednesday
right oh thank you
oh she came to our Halloween day as
Wednesday
Adams she she rocked it it was really
good and she was very polite and didn't
It uncle fer Uncle Fester yes yes I
can
thank you got it
appreciate yeah folks if you're
interested in going on either or both of
those uh committees we put together this
morning uh just send me a note thank you
representative
Perez
that by the way is The Final
Countdown I played that before wedding
once they had been engaged for like
eight years and I was the organist that
wedding and they were goofballs both of
them and I figured what the heck and so
I did my nice 20 minute concert and they
were late and when the bride finally
came around the corner I gave a rousing
chorus of The Final Countdown and they
likeed that much more than um
which was The Wedding March yeah okay do
I have a who is do I have a card introdu
this Miss
Dyer may I
open the hearing on Senate Bill 498 FN
relative to the Department of Health
Human Services Division for children
youth and families in today's exciting
episode the part of Senator Bradley is
being played by the chair so I am
introducing this bill and I have some
Allstar cast of people ready to speak to
it and some written documents so the
larabe good afternoon chairman Pearson
and members of the children and family
law committee my name is Susan laraby I
am general counsel and chief of
legislative affairs for DCF good
afternoon uh this um is a d a
DHHS uh requested Bill and I'm here to
provide information for you and to go
over the bill Senate Bill
498 basically Senate Bill 498 uh in the
first section uh align and adds language
the Juvenile Justice delinquency section
of
169b which is in on page one sections 1
through 4 which would be lines 1 through
30 as well as 169 d which is children in
need of services which begins on page
two and that's line 15 continuing onto
page three through line 13 basically
what the the added language aligns with
the child protection act of
169c uh pertaining to the placement
options uh for children that is
consistent with federal law the family
first Prevention Services Act of
2017 which allows for not just relative
caregivers but Kinship Caregivers to uh
be a placement option for children not
just with uh CPA with the child
protection act but for children involved
with the juvenile justice system in both
the delinquency and shins act and that
language of adding kinship would be
aligning with that with both federal and
state law as well as adding the
placement options of certified
residential or psychiatric placements
that is also part of the children
protection
act uh secondly on page two uh section
five which is lines 1 through 14 will be
amending the reporting dates of the
Youth Detention Center logs uh those
reports go to the department um of
Health and Human Services uh by anually
and the way it's stated in the statute
now the dates of reporting are uh
January 1st and July 1st we request that
the bill be amended as the language
dates in Senate Bill 498 to align itself
with the federal reporting dates of the
Juvenile Justice delinquency prevention
act which would change the dates uh
reporting to October 1st and April 1st
and lastly uh this bill on page three
which is uh section 10 of the bill uh
lines 14 through 19 this bill would
repeal the perspective repeal of the
section known as the rebuttable
presumption of harm that went into
effect in
2021 with House Bill 1162 that had a
sunset provision of July first of this
year of 2024 so this bill would be
repealing the repeal of that sunset
provision we have asked for that because
we find that the rebuttable presumption
of harm is a very important evidentiary
tool it is trauma informed with all that
we know about Early Childhood adverse
effects it does not change the
definition of neglect that's why it's an
evidentiary tool under 169
C12 the definition of neglect Remains
the Same it's a two-prong definition in
which a child is a neglected child is a
who is without proper care necessary for
the child's physical mental or emotional
well-being and then that second prong is
that when it is established that a child
has suffered serious impairment or is
likely to suffer serious impairment I
know it's it's a mouthful and there's
many elements involved with uh what
factors uh the court is to consider when
looking at serious
impairments and the Supreme Court has
has simplified it to be harm harm to a
child or potential harm arm to a child
and that's the hard part sometimes in
court because that's not in line with
what we know about Early Childhood
adverse effects and that harm occurred
but it may not immediately manifest
itself it may not be readily apparent to
a child who has been exposed to certain
situation and experiences in their home
and
therefore that would prevent sometimes
the state from acting from intervening
or delay intervention waiting for that
harm to manifest itself and that's not
in line what what we all as a society
know about Early Childhood adverse
effects and therefore four years ago as
my understanding that the
legislature heard testimony from many
entities including um a review of the
federal review of cases that were not uh
acted upon and saw that consistently
those were the ones that were considered
to be exposure cases when children were
exposed to certain conditions in the
home and those conditions put them at
risk of serious impairment so therefore
House Bill 1162 which did a lot of great
things for child welfare it finally
defined psychological melt treatment it
finally included a stepparent as a
parent of a child and it included four
rebuttable presumptions of harm in which
the the court may make a finding that a
child has been harmed a rebuttable
presumption that this child has been
harmed unless in until proven otherwise
to certain exposure cases and that is
when a child is exposed to substance
misuse in the home that is adversely
affecting the care of the child when a
child is exposed to driving while
intoxicated by being in the car with a
parent who is driving while impaired
three when a child is exposed osed to
physical violence in the home by the
parent the parent is either physically
uh violent towards another child in the
home or another adult in the home and
that child is exposed to that and lastly
when a child is exposed to psychological
melt treatment either they themselves
are the victim of psychological melt
treatment or they are exposed to psych
psychological M treatment in the home to
another adult or another child in the
home and that is a very important
evidentiary tool that we hope with the
passage of this bill uh that you pass
this bill to repeal the repeal of that
those rebuttable presumptions of
harm and I be happy to answer any
questions about the bill under those
four three of them are very discreet
situations but I question about
psychological maltreatment how broadly
could that be taken for example the
child really wants something and the
parent parents for whatever reason do
not believe that the child should have
that uh we're talking major things um
would that be considered psychological
maltreatment and the child could say I
wanted to have tattoos and my parents
forbad me and because of that I am
suffering uh to me psychological Mal
treatment could be it could be runaway
if I may with House Bill 1162 the
definition of psychological Mel
treatment was added to the definition
section of 169 C3 and if you could give
me a moment I believe I did bring the
actual statute with me well if you
perfect I can go so before I joined DCF
as a as a uh general counsel I worked
for UNH and I was um a trainer and after
1162 was passed and included the
provision that all dcyf and other
stakeholders be trained on House Bill
1162 and I was actually a trainer of
that so I will refer to my PRI previous
notes on the trainings that were some
definition
for
it defines cycle the law the statute of
1162 added to the definition of
psychological Mal treatment and was
added into the law of pervasive and
emotionally abusive Behavior which shall
include but not be limited to patterns
of threatening berating or demeaning
Behavior so it's a course of conduct of
behavior that is threatening berating or
demeaning parents being parents and
saying know you cannot do that would not
fall under any of those unless the
language used and so it becomes a
berating language or physical
threatening language correct because as
we know uh you know emotional abuse and
words have sometimes a lot more effects
on a child than oh sure but sometimes
saying no a child can perceive that of
course and that's why I think um you all
if anyone was present during the house
bill 1162 took all of that in
consideration and talked about pervasive
and emotionally abusive Behavior yeah I
was a co-sponsor to that so I just want
to make sure I didn't uh you know open
up something representative
dmon thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so when I raised
my children I had a sign on the
refrigerator that I replaced frequently
because I had to get the Jelly stains
off and it said um Sticks and Stones can
break your bones but words can break
your
heart and I always said to the children
be careful how you speak to somebody so
I found
it diff difficult for myself when I
reported somebody for calling their
child an effing moronic
idiot and when I reported it as abuse I
was told sorry so it seems like this
bill am I correct that this bill will
make a corrective action in that aspect
when you're const L verbally Bering and
telling a child that they are not what
they what you are telling them they
are exactly because it's patterns of
threatening berading or demeaning
Behavior so in the court of law that' be
very hard to prove that a child has been
harmed without this rebuttable
presumption of
harm about time thank you representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my call do you have any
um why um what was the sorry I'm What
would I'm just wondering it's baffling
what was the reason for uh the repeal of
that that's a good question I don't know
actually the origin of why it has sunset
provision in it um I know that these
rebuttable presumption of harms the four
of them replaced the opioid um
rebuttable presumption that had a sun
set so I don't know if that's why it was
replacing another provision that did
Sunset but other than that I would be
only
guessing
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um I actually wanted to just go
back to um the first and second parts of
the bills can you just um explain
fictive Ken and what that legal
definition is for us just because it's
something new since I worked at dcyf
years
ago I can uh fictive kin is defined in
17025 Roman numeral 8 in which kin means
a child means a child or children who
for which there is a connection or
history between a child or their parents
and another responsible adult including
but not incl not limited to a relative
or related adult so someone known to the
child it can be a relative but doesn't
have to be a relative it can be a coach
it can be a teacher it can be a
great the yes representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson thank
you for your time and coming to answer
our questions
um there's something about this that's
just not sitting right with me um at the
current moment because you're saying
threatening Bering and demeaning which
is which are all very subjective which
means we're placing our values on
another family without even the evidence
that there is harm being done I know
that I understand that over the long run
you know children we all have stories
about what our parents might have done
to us um but I'm concerned and I'm just
wondering how does this
fit um when you talk about psychological
maltreatment
where does parents that have diagnosed
mental illness of by maybe borderline
personality or bipolar
disorder is this going to
unfairly impact them because that's how
they could tend to treat their children
with a lot of threatening behavior or
Bering or um especially with a about one
minute they're they're happy go-lucky
parents and the next minute they're
screaming at their children so I'm just
wondering how is this going to affect
our community that is diagnosed and is
that going to stop people from getting
from getting help for their um mental
health
issues thank you for the question well
first of all it's twofold the rebuttable
presumption of harm is applying
psychological Mel treatment that
definition is is defined in the
definition section of 169 C3 and that is
not part of the repeal the repeal is the
rebuttable presumption of harm and again
it's a rebuttable presumption it's not
an irrebuttable presumption of harm so
if there's testimony that the parent was
repeatedly um calling a child a a
derogatory name in terms of calling them
uh obese and what that means to be
calling them obese and did certain
actions because they called them obese
or uh did other forms of emotional abuse
that's a rebuttable presumption it's not
irrebuttable until unless proven
otherwise it just makes it easier to
prove harm but it's not saying it is
harm in and of
itself followup follow
up so just to to make sure I'm getting
this clear so I understand that it's a
rebuttable but it's also presenting an
opportunity for parents to go after each
other in making claims against the other
parent for what they would perceive as
mistreatment or
um I'm just I guess I'm I'm worried
about this subjectiveness of it of
especially when it's something that
you're not seeing it's just something
maybe I wouldn't particularly raise my
children doing it one way so I'm I'm
trying to understand and square this
whole thing is how do
we one is how do you prove it but also
how do you disprove an
allegation well I think you have to also
start the foundation of that all
evidence in court has to be material
reliable and found to be credible for it
to be found to even apply the rebble
presumption of harm so typically say for
instance if there's a child who goes to
the Child Advocacy Center and has a
forensic interview in which the child
describes acts of the parent that is
emotionally abusive and berading and
that is evidence that's material
evidence it's reliable evidence it's
credible evidence that the state would
put into evidence during an abuse and
neglect action for psychological melt
treatment and that evidence is weighed
by the judge so doesn't doesn't change
like I said it before it doesn't first
it doesn't change the um evidence of
putting in reliable credible evidence
it's just that once that evidence is
ruled to be reliable and
credible uh admissible evidence then the
judge weighs that with the evidentiary
tool of a rebuttable presumption of
harm the chair welcomes attorne Attorney
John Williams to where he is now seated
and and thank you very much chairman uh
for the record my name is John Williams
I'm the legislative director for Health
Human Services and just here to
compliment the testimony that's being
provided to you very astute uh testimony
um from attorney larby uh I actually was
involved with the underlying Bill
working with many of you on the
committee that dealt with the rebuttable
presumption around harm what I wanted to
clarify particularly for you represent
ball that is actually currently in law
today and the reason the sunset
provision was placed into the bill was
primarily at the request of the
pediatricians in from Dartmouth and
other areas because they were concerned
about the perhaps chilling effect that
would have in terms of reporting uh in
cases where a parent might have a
subance a subance use um matter and so
we have worked with them very
collaboratively you heard from attorney
larby about the training that we've done
for the interpretation to making sure
that we're very sensitive because we
want people to address their subs use
issues and also we want to make sure
that kids are safe and I think we've
done a really good job balancing the the
um whole perspective of the current law
now the sunset was put in here
specifically for this to be rot tested
and I'm not saying because you don't
hear clamors of hundreds of people
behind us that that is evidence because
that's kind of lack of evidence uh but
it is an occasion where this has been
rot tested and gone through the process
and that's why we're here today to
request this committee to remove the
sunset provision again the issues that
you're you're discussing are are in
current law there not this is nothing
new that this bill is trying to do it's
just eliminating the sunset provision in
the law because it is working and it is
protecting kids and if it isn't working
in the future you will certainly have
folks coming before you seeking other
changes of law but we're not trying to
change at all and I'll repeat we're not
trying to change at all the current
provisions of the law as it relates to
the um rebuttable uh proof of harm so
attorney larby
anything I have a question um some of
you may remember House Bill 5
1973 which was about outplacement of
children who needed to be placed
somewhere and there
was there were hours upon hours upon
hours of work that went into that by the
office of the child advocate and
Department of Health and Human Services
and one poor legislator who really
wonders um please tell me that this 498
is in is in a different place it is not
um dealing with 1573 or it's Senate
cousin I think it's 417 this is uh
something different
correct thank you yeah and and I don't
say the same word uh chairman that you
also say about certain types of bills
and I probably met a couple of your
folks returning from lunch that I did
this uh this truly is one of those bills
that were coming back again the Fred kin
very helpful pieces around Family First
putting that into legislation changing a
the date for reporting for detention
from January 1st to October uh are the
periods that we had under the federal
and then finally just seeking not any
change to current law as it relates to
rebuttal Pro for harm but just uh
addressing the sunset provision if we do
if you do nothing here today what will
end up happening is that it is scheduled
a sunset on June 30th of of this year
and so that's why we're here very
thoughtfully to saying it's working it's
been Road tested and if there's any
other changes needed people will come to
you our only goal here is to address the
sunset
further thank you counselor and thank
you counselor thank you all thank you
this now ends the hearing on Senate Bill
498 and uh we're done we're done where
card that's not the
point the question is we usually have
the cards do you have something you want
to
softy chair recognizes Vice chair Erica
Leon from Health and Human Service
elderly Affairs committee uh thank you
Mr chairman I apologize for not passing
that up Sumer I remember you called
calling many last calls for cards in the
I'm sorry for being
grumpy um I I'm representative Erica
Leon I represent the town of dairy um I
come to speak to you about my concern
about um one particular phrase that is
included in here fictive kin um my
concern around that is as I was looking
through the statutes I know it was
referenced but I did not find it in our
existing statutes and I also um am just
quite concerned about the possibility of
placing children
with somebody who may not may have an
inappropriate relationship with them and
may be in a position of authority um my
mother was a public school teacher and
um the only way that they found out that
there was a teacher who had Decades of
inappropriate relationships with
children was after the teacher's lounge
was vandalized in a horrific way because
the same thing had happened to one Boy's
brother that had happened to him until
that day that teacher was well- loved
and well respected but they found out
that there had been a pattern of abuse
over decades um my concern is simply
around the fictive kin I recognize the
need to make sure that there are people
who are important to a child who are
involved when I first heard about this I
asked what's victed of King kin oh that
must be Uncle Mike my husband's best
friend from growing up who is the one
who will be raising our children should
something happen to us um and we have
that in documentation I know not
everybody else does but my caution here
is that there are people who are
involved in children's lives there's one
from my town who had been um an
assistant at a school and she has
another parole hearing coming up she had
an inappropriate relationship with one
of the students what if he had been
placed in that house um the horrors that
had happened there would have been even
worse so I had just some caution on
expanding the ease of placement in
fictive kin because you know I'd say
probably 99,900 99 out of 10,000 people
who would be in that situation are good
but we need to be sure that that balance
of power and the potential for an
inappropriate relationship with somebody
in a position of power isn't something
that moves a child from the frying pan
Into the
Fire any questions for vice chair Leon
representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um do you
believe that there are also um people
who are relatives and
Guardians um who also are abusers and
it's already in law that they would
be able to be responsible for this
child's care yes and that was one of the
challenges and tragedies that faces
especially this committee dealing with
those difficulties because you can't you
need to treat everybody fairly and
sometimes there's bad people that are
able to disguise how they act um and
it's the challenge if this was easy all
these kids would be safe um and I
commend you guys for everything you do
in order to protect children followup
please followup so um with that
um with that being said I think it's
logical that um we would have to treat
everybody in in uh that's presently in
statute and also fictive kin in the same
way um in order to uh vet them equally
because we would have to to um view all
of them as uh you know potentially
either very good equally or harmfully
potentially um so how would you like
what what would be the difference in
vetting those two types of people well
thank you for that question um I I
recognize the vetting process is
challenging it's something that actually
is probably worth some evaluation and to
see what that vetting process is and to
make sure that in certain situations
it's not fast tracked just because of a
good feeling about somebody um that's
something that I promise I'll look into
and see if there's something that can be
done in terms of that however the more
that we open this up to to additional
people the more that the the more
opportunities for problems there are yet
I also understand we don't want to be
putting children into homes we don't
want to be shipping them out of state we
don't want to be putting them somewhere
else but we need to acknowledge the fact
that there can be um you inappropriate
relationships representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman my question is
actually for you Mr chairman can we ask
um DCF what or the representatives from
DHHS what the vetting process is for
placement with um people who aren't
certified foster homes or certified
placement representative I was just
about to do that oh thank you so thank
you for seconding
that because I I think the
Representative makes a good point
thank you if you're done with me I'll
step away from here thank you for
hearing me
Cher nothing thank you thank you now how
about representative Raymond's
question you're it guys you too you're
you represent all 4800 DC uh DHHS
employees well thank you um yeah so back
in 2022 kinship Care Homes were added to
the definition of foster care um uh
facilities uh kinship Care Home Means A
type of foster home in which an
individual or individuals are licens to
provide care exclusively to Kin and then
like I said before kin is defined as I
read that definition earlier uh there
shall be a maximum of six children in
the home and children uh and children
receive for child care who are related
to the residents um those six other
people uh we are currently in a contract
with um an organization called a a
chance they are the ones that are
licensing uh these kinship Care Homes um
so once they are licensed they are able
to receive foster care payments because
that was the hurdle that many uh
relatives and fictive kin were being
vetted but were unable to receive foster
care payments and maintenance for the
care of these children so based on the
changes to the statute in
2022 these kinship homes will be our LIC
are being licensed and will continue to
be licensed and during that licensing
process there's obviously a an
application a vetting um a home study um
a study uh background checks and and all
that goes into um making sure that the
child is placed in a safe and
appropriate home that is with someone
they
know follow up thank you Mr chairman so
in so what happens when there's an
emergency or even in in this case where
a delinquency has happened and a child
needs
placement do they have to go to a group
home while the you know the you know
Uncle Mike or whomever is being vetted
through the vetting process or can they
go there like on a conditional basis
while the my understanding again my
understanding is I'm not the subject
matter expert at this but this is my
understanding working on the uh
licensing process with kinship Care
Homes is that there are certain things
that are called day one non-negotiable
that have to be done that day one to in
order to place um uh child with the
uncle and that uncle has to have a
background check which would require the
uh cpsw to call the local PDS to come in
observe the home do a walkth through of
the home and answer ask and be answered
a certain non-negotiable questions
regarding safety of that child and then
after that the more formal vet goes in
terms of the FBI fingerprinting the
background checks the central sexual um
I'm sorry the central registry uh for
abuse and neglect the sex offender
registry uh and other um processes of
individual thank you okay oh one more
pink
card uh chair recognizes The Honorable
an
America
representative this isn't written down
Betty gay from Salem and I'm going to uh
try to IM give a example of what
representative Nelson referred to I had
never heard of fictive kin until January
when a person who I now I can't name
them because it does involve a child but
a person that you've heard many times so
you'd have respect for had a child
15-year-old knock on her door and ask if
she could have a drink of water she had
been walking
from she'd been walking a long time
turns out everybody at school and the
police knew this child's
situation the person abusing her was her
aunt's
husband so she could have been there but
thank goodness for fictive kin this
person whose home she just decided to
walk up to because it looked like a
place people came to they had a sign out
front
um this child the school knew the
situation and the police actually had
her real aunt say to them that very day
I don't want
her um and because it just like it was
pre-ordained It was supposed to happen
this child is now under their care it
was established
immediately because of the fictive kin a
a
permission I'm not sure what word to use
but because it is
allowed she this child could once again
go into a home and be cared for while
they were doing all the steps necessary
because if they had waited for the um
for them to complete the foster care
that would have taken a few months
meanwhile this child needed shelter
immediately and so the story that's how
I found out about it because I was
called would you be a reference you know
a personal reference for the the uh new
fictive
parents so I thought I had to say this
because as our representative Nelson
pointed
out you don't want to send a child
anywhere where they're not going to be
cared for safely but you can't just
assume that because they are relatives
that it's any safer than someone that
you're vetting and have a relationship
with so I certainly support continuing
continuing the uh fictive relationship
qualifying people to be uh caretakers of
children who need a safe home any
questions for the retired
representative thank you thank you you
know we all knew what this was it was
that nice person down the road that was
gosh he's more close to me than my
biological aunt and uncle are we just
didn't know what the term is so I think
we've all had um knowledge of fictive
except for the title well what do you
think folks ready to go ahead on this
one too all right yes representative uh
um uh Raymond was that a hand no I meant
it to be a thumbs up oh that was more
than one thumb
okay all right who would like to move
OTP and write the blurb oh this ends the
hearing on S SP 498 and this opens the
exec session on it as well who would
line I'll I'll make the motion I can
have the sheet and the motion is is uh
the motion is OTP on 498 please thank
you and who is that representative
deimon okay and let's roll on this one
because she's got to leave yep 498
relative to DCF moved by representative
Raymond second by representative D
Simone clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman
long yes representative disimon yes
representative
Bickford not here at the moment
Nelson Nelson Nelson uh representative
McMahon yes representative ball
representative panck yes representative
Melvin yes representative
grman yes representative LC is not
present representative Patrina will vote
Yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Raymond yes that would be 13 to zero to
zero consent
yes good thank you this ends the uh exec
session on S SP 498 it also ends our day
and once again on the first two bills we
saw that were establishing committees if
you would like to be on one or both of
them please either email me or give me a
note
accordingly and there we
are hey on second chance today vet
household members also did I vet
household
members
do they do they vet on Second Chance do
they vet household members also yeah
okay
so order to that and even if
it's